manos levantadas al unísono con tristeza
y con rabia llegaron para protestar en
contra de la violencia de género y así
la asesinato de una niña de seis años
miles de mujeres se reunieron en toda
españa para denunciar el maltrato
doméstico y pedir el fin de los
feminicidios en madrid la multitud coreó
aquí estamos las feministas y expresó su
indignación yo siento una rabia inmensa
una impotencia que no te puedo explicar
tenemos mucha pena en este país
cientos y cientos de muertes
[Aplausos]
al ritmo de no estamos todas faltan las
muertas estás manifestantes en barcelona
aseguraron que el último golpe fue el
trágico destino de anahí olivia el 27 de
abril las dos niñas fueron secuestradas
por su padre tras decirle a su madre que
no las volvería a ver el jueves
encontraron el cuerpo de ana de 6 años
en el mar su hermana de un año sigue
desaparecida al igual que el principal
sospechoso su padre la historia ha
conmocionado a españa con la reina y el
presidente expresando sus condolencias y
muchos otros su indignación digamos yo
creo que muchos meses esperando poder
explotar de alguna manera peñas a la
bolivia se niega que sean crimen
machista cuando realmente es para
matar en vida
también desde 2013 se han registrado mil
96 feminicidios en el país y 18 en lo
que va de año 10 de ellos en las últimas
5 semanas aunque españa ha sido alabada
por intentar acabar con el problema pero
con la pandemia aumento de la violencia
doméstica y ahora con la relajación de
las medidas muchas mujeres han intentado
dejar a sus parejas maltratadoras por lo
que los feminicidios han aumentado